he's the commissioner major league
baseball he's rob manfred back on the
program
commissioner thanks for joining us if
this commissioner
at this time could give advice to the
commissioner back in march
what would you have said to that
commissioner yourself back in march
well um you know look hindsight is 20 20
dan um there were parts of what we went
through in march that
i would like to replay obviously
i hate any situation where we have
a disagreement with the players
association that
gets public um so you know i would like
that one over
on the other hand we stuck to our guns
on a couple of
issues that were really really important
a lot of people wanted us to lengthen
the season you know
suggestions about playing large numbers
of games and pushing out
into november i think if you look at
what's going on with respect to the
virus
right now it was really um
a good decision to finish the season on
time and maintain that that was
important
i think secondly you know there was also
a push to schedule a lot of double
headers
and we can play more games i mean i mean
the fact of the matter is
we wouldn't have finished the 60 had we
had
uh not had the scheduling flexibility to
add double headers to reschedule
for games that that we lost so look it
wasn't perfect
um and you know i do regret the
publicity part of it
uh but we got to 60 games and that's a
good outcome for us
how close were you to not playing or
shutting down
this season we had a serious problem
i mean i've said it publicly you know
after the st
louis situation or during the saint
louis situation as our second
outbreak i was really nervous about our
ability
to continue to go forward um you know we
had
really good conversations with tony
clark in the mlbpa we strengthened the
protocols
he helped us educate the players on the
importance of certain aspects of those
protocols
and fortunately we were able to
to play through and i think we're in day
55
without a positive test yeah
where do we stand on the dh for next
season
i think in all likelihood we will return
um
i mean i think all of the covid related
rule changes right and in that bucket
it's the
x training rule the seven inning double
headers the dh in the national league
those rules we will return to the status
quo absent agreement with the players
association
what would you like to keep
well you know i've tried to be careful
about this
and despite being careful about how i
said it keeps getting reported you know
rob manford wants this rob manfred wants
that the only
um thing that i i can say that i've made
my mind up about and
i actually made my mind up about it
pre-covered was i would like to expand
the playoffs
um i don't think 16 teams is the right
number but something bigger than 10 is
right and i
i we will pursue that either next year
the the the following year
with respect to the rest of the rules i
haven't really made my mind up as to
which ones
um we might consider keeping um what i
have said is i think the extreme rule
within the game
um you know players owners a lot of
people like that rule it got some
positive press
in the media i think people appreciate
the
strategy associated with the rule and
kind of the
finality in terms of increased finality
in terms of
when the game's going to end um but you
know i have made my mind up as to
whether i want to push for that i
wondered about the shift as well
and i wonder i mean i'm okay with the
shift
but i wonder if can you make it where
the shortstop can't go on the other side
of second base or vice versa like how
much of a shift
are you going to allow other sports
have you know you can take it to a
certain
point a certain extreme but this has
become an extreme with major league
baseball is it good for the game
to have these shifts i i think the
competition committee
um is having conversations about a
variety of rule changes
and i know one that um has received an
extensive
uh amount of attention is the shift um a
lot of people feel that
the extreme shifting that you're talking
about let me use your word
okay yeah um has changed the game in
ways that are not positive and it
remains a really
um hot topic in terms of conversations
within that committee and i expect more
to follow on that one
and i i've been a get off my lawn guy
this week because
i'm looking at baseball and there's no
movement when we were growing up
you had movement in the game you would
hit to the other side of the infield you
would bunt
you take the extra bass like just the
simple things of what you learn when
you're
playing baseball baseball has become i
throw it hard and you swing really hard
and nothing in between
how concerned are you about you know you
always talk about growing the game like
you like where the game is right now
when you're watching this game
is this a good is this entertainment i
think there is
a widespread consensus in the game
that we've become too dependent on walks
strikeouts and home runs as
what goes on in our game i think people
within the game
within the ownership ranks want to see
more
traditional action in the game and
there's a lot of conversation going on
about how you motivate players
um to play the game in that way um
it's very hard to legislate action with
your rule
um what you're really doing is you're
creating you're changing the rules in a
way that creates incentives
for some of the greatest athletes in the
world to change the way they're playing
and that's a very complicated task
i get that i just worry about the game
if i'm
11 or 12 or 13 i would have no interest
in this i don't think i would watch
highlights i wouldn't watch
games and i don't know if you're finding
that out that
you know this is a entertain me now i'm
not in it for the long haul
and and so you're losing if uh i think
another generation
fan base well i i hope you're wrong uh
uh
about that dan you know we've we've
really focused on the next generation in
a variety of ways our participation
numbers which
actually are the is the biggest
determinant of whether young people
become fans are
are great i mean we have been the
fastest growing participation sport over
the last five years
we've invested heavily in that area um
and you know our demographics um
particularly on some of our digital
products um
things new products like film room are
really very good
in in terms of engaging that younger
audience
and i think we will continue to focus on
action in the game
in order to make sure we hold those
younger people um that we're attracting
that we're attracting and i want to be
wrong commissioner i think
i think afternoon baseball was great
afternoon
post-season baseball is great because
we all i mean i was watching fisk when
he's waving the ball fair
you know gibson hits the home run
against eck i i was able you know you're
staying up to watch those games
i just feel like you know kids today
start time might not be able to stay up
games take a lot longer um
yeah but think about our new round dan i
mean i i know
it's important to focus on the world
series and and you know like all
entertainment products
um we have to deliver an audience for
our broadcast partners yeah but
focused on the additional round i mean
you you had baseball on
post season baseball on oh i love that
won't day long
i love it yes and even all the way
can we keep it going though commissioner
yeah i look i think that it but think
about it so the lcs
the additional round we talked about the
division series we had games that were
four
on a day so we had plenty of daytime
baseball even the lcs
the early game you know was a late
afternoon start most of the time
and you know we do need to have those
earlier starts
but the reality is with your um premier
product the world series
we have to work with fox who's been a
great partner
to us to deliver the biggest audience we
can you know
the demographics on audience are
interesting too dan
um we don't get
that much younger in our audience by
playing earlier it's shocking to people
um but you know we actually
hold our young people with later games
people apparently let their kids stay up
um i know it's a popular theory it is
not supported by the numbers
no uh hey i'm i'm i'm learning i
i sit humbly here listening to some of
this
oh i don't need to be pedantic dan
really you know no way
now who did you just wink to oh mr
courtney's sitting on me
okay so pat courtney there okay i see
like all right hey
i got him with that one wink wink i saw
it
i saw it there well done the gatekeeper
pat courtney
you are very observant
um the other thing is i always wondered
about this growing up we got
if you got straight a seats in
cincinnati or tickets
uh you get uh straight a's you could
turn it in and get a couple of games to
go to and they put you out in center
field they weren't great seats but
you're in the ballpark
i would love to see more teams just get
5 000 in there or 10 000 in there
and it doesn't cost anything but the
experience of coming there the first
time
concessions parking all of that stuff
why are we missing out or am i missing
something here because that just feels
like
i want you to get that first experience
because chances are then you'll come
back i want repeat business
can i you know i actually spent some of
baseball's money
to confirm the intuition that you just
expressed
after playing the game um the most
important thing in building a fan as an
adult
is getting a kid in the ballpark younger
and like the difference between
that young person going when he's eight
and going when he's 12 is actually
significant in terms of how many games
they consume as an adult so we have a
league-wide initiative with the clubs um
to get young people in the ballpark
particularly in groups
um like you suggest um one that i saw
last year when we still were had fans in
the ballpark
you know i went to miami for a game is
one of their best attendance games of
the year
it was basically filled with little
leaguers which is awesome
and it's really good for growing the
game the red sox
have another you know a team that does
draw yeah right has less tickets to work
with
they have a great program they have a
separate entrance for young people
everything in the experience is
family oriented kid-oriented to make
sure that that first trip to the
ballpark is as positive as possible
but your intuition is right on the money
it's something baseball really needs to
focus on yeah and i didn't get straight
a's
but somebody that i knew got straight
a's and then we got tickets
i got to see the padres with those
god-awful uniforms back in the 1970s
you know i there should be a c section
oh i just came up with a double entendre
the c-section
where if you get c's you get to sit in
that section
i got a laugh out of pat
however you reward the kids however you
decide who gets to go
we need to make sure they're going to
the ballpark and are you rooting for the
dodgers or the raise commissioner
i am strictly neutral um i always
look for the team that is behind
in the series you want seven games i
think the best thing for our fans is
more baseball
um so i wrote to uh the owner of the
race
yesterday morning i said i like nothing
better than a gritty team
who wins the second game to tie the
series at 1-1
take a victory lap you did a great job
yeah you hung in there
yeah you limped towards the finish line
in the regular season you felt off a lot
of pitches but
uh you know you're gonna pull this off
yeah well you know what i think it's a
good thing for the game the
the owners um
and the players worked really hard
together to make this happen i can't say
enough about the effort involved i mean
you you ask a player not only to change
the way
he performs on the field his habits
even when he gets to the ballpark that's
a lot of change but it didn't stop there
we asked them to change their private
lives too and um they need to be
commended for the contribution they made
to
getting us across the finish line here
well hopefully we get five more games
you'd be happy with that right
i would dance i would thank you
commissioner and of course more
importantly thank you to
pat courtney there for helping make this
happen
maybe we'll put him on stream next time
yeah might as well
might as well he makes this happen thank
you commissioner
all right great that's the commissioner
major league baseball